- Listen, you have to understand
just 'cause you're a human being
doesn't mean you're entitled to
be a successful entrepreneur.
They do what everybody
else does in every genre.
You want to be an NFL player,
an NBA player you try
you're not good enough,
you do something else.
You want to be a famous actor,
you go to LA, you wait tables
you try to be on a show,
it doesn't happen,
you do something else.
I don't know what they do.
Like, something else but
they're not gonna build
a million dollar business.
Guys, do you know how
many million dollar businesses
are actually built that sustain?
The data is not in our favor.
And I'm not trying
to be cloudy in this sun.
I'm trying to save
people some money
and some heartache and
create some upside.
This is just practicality.
It's just data.
We're not talking about it and
listen, a lot of you
know my spiel.
I'm not excited
to talk about this.
I'm happy-go-lucky.
I'm positive. I'm crushin'
but I'm fuckin' telling
you the truth.
It's just here right now
and what that means,
by the way, let me explain.
A lot of you have businesses
that can actually be successful.
The problem is you
have 17 employees
when you should have five.
A lot of you have businesses
that can be successful
but you want to
have a nice office, right,
in SoHo instead of
being somewhere shitty.
Right? A lot of you could have
businesses that are successful
but you come to fuckin'
(censored) and waste time
instead of building
your business.
(audience laughter and cheers)
- Not that last part.
- That last part and
all the other shit.
Are you building a business?
You better fuckin'
work tomorrow.
And the only reason some of
you will is 'cause it's gonna
rain 'cause if it was like
this today tomorrow
you'd all be somewhere
and that's just losing.
And that's happening at scale.
- How many 25-year-olds
don't do the cool ideas
on the projected thing
that they're gonna go
buy themselves an office.
- Of course and by the way,
a good percentage of them
are gonna win.
I hope you're sitting there
and getting mad at me
and saying, "Fuck this guy,"
and I can't wait to get your emails
saying, "Oh you said I wasn't
gonna win at (censored).
"I built a
$100 million business."
Respect.
Great.
I want that.
I hope every fucking person
looking at my face
right now wins everything.
Money, life, health, great.
I want that more
than anybody. Why not?
Be the greatest.
I just think there's an enormous
lack of practicality right now.
- Alright, let's move it
in the positive direction.
- That was positive.
(audience laughter)
That was the
positive direction.
- More in the
- That was the positive.
- Let's follow up on that
and keep that train going.
- I think that's positive
instead of people pontificating
here like, "Yeah, we're
all gonna fucking do it."